luke tom and nate here with the outdoor
boys youtube channel we're here in
talkeetna
alaska and we're about to get on a jet
boat
head up river into the bush and go
camping fishing
and just having a great adventure in
some serious bear country you guys ready
yeah yeah
we're here with phantom river charters
and for a very reasonable price
they will take you and drop you off
various locations
along the river and pick you up whenever
you want and so we
are going to camp all night and fish for
uh silvers pinks chums
trout it's it's going to be awesome and
i think we might be eating some fresh
salmon tonight but they are around but
somebody got mauled down by gerdwood
last week
uh they're scared of you yes she is
she's your navigator and can you go
these jet boat rides are awesome
look at this we could not ask for more
beautiful weather here down there with
the byu
all right guys so this is the talkeetna
river
and this right here is the big suscita
river these rivers are no joke man you
don't drive a boat on this thing unless
you know what you're doing
highest mountain in north america mount
denali
we're going to be flying over that on
friday we're here
filming in alaska for six weeks so if
you guys
want to see the entire six week
adventure
make sure you click subscribe and look
down in the video description we're
gonna put a link
to our entire adventure as we post it
[Music]
oh look at that i can see fish look at
all the salmon here
[Music]
there's just hundreds and hundreds of
pink salmon in here
we get a lot of them
there's a lot of these creeks that dump
in and these are all
great fishing spots for salmon look at
all this for the big red ones
are silvers the red ones are silvers the
gray ones are pinks they call them
pinks because their meat is pink not
because their skin is pink
the ones that turn pink have red or
orange meat well red's taking us
up the river and showing us a couple
different creeks and a couple different
places we can camp
and uh we're just going to go ahead and
pick one and
see what see what happens i mean this is
just
well we're spoiled for choices
[Music]
well rhett thank you very much we'll see
you tomorrow
here we go guys
we're in alaska now folks there goes our
ride
our connection to civilization and i now
got to find out where the boys ran off
to
yeah that is a bear prank that's a small
bear
this place is called clear creek and you
can see
how it got its name look at how clear
that is
and there's salmon right in there i can
already see salmon there's one right
there there's one right there
there's one right there oh there's a
bunch right there
i mean they're only in 10 inches of
water i mean you don't need to cast out
far
deep to get into fish this is gonna be
awesome
all right we've been here five minutes
and nathan's socks are already wet
that's pretty standard
fired
all right
you guys having fun yeah
number one bait for salmon salmon eggs
they love to eat their own eggs it's got
like a number two hook
with i've tied an egg loop knot this
little retractable reusable loop go and
we're gonna hook this on
put it around there pull it tight
there we go
got my rod sitting here in a fork stick
and i've got another stick right here in
front of the reel
to keep a fish from stealing my rod
hits already
do this hold it hold it he's taking line
look at that toss
[Music]
how's that
there you go well there we go that was
about an 18-inch rainbow trout man that
was pretty nice
drink it jerk it drink it hold on
this is a wonderful truck oh there he
goes he popped off
yay all right just to mix it up i've got
some eggs
underneath the float no lead slightly
bigger hooks so we might miss some of
those trout
we're gonna check that out there and see
what happens
yeah he's pulling some drag oh
nathan nathan that's a monster
keep that run up keep it right over the
air buddy don't let him pull your rod
down
there you go oh keep that up
that's a silver buddy that's not a big
rainbow
look at that oh look at him look at the
mark he's got on him that's like where a
seal bit him
did you find the big rock if you can't
find a rock daddy's got this
there we go that is a lovely silver
look at this oh
it's another beautiful silver he
devoured that
oh my goodness it is on fire we have
gotten two silvers in five minutes
i need to get myself a stringer to keep
these guys fresh
yep this water is like 40 degrees so
it's the second best thing to a cooler
hand right here okay look go go see that
see that see that
yeah oh you got to hit it go for it hit
it hit him hit it
hit it hit it hit it yeah you got him
there you go oh it's a beauty
here walk over here walk to shore walk
to shore
oh walk to shore okay don't reel anymore
just walk
keep pulling pulling along the shore
pull up on the shore
there we go buddy you're you're first
silver
well the boys are saying they're hungry
as they should be it's a little past
lunch time
and i put the rod in the rod holder with
some bells and uh we're gonna get them
some snacks i've got
soft lemon cookies and
cherry strudels and we are having a very
unhealthy but delicious lunch
got one buddy
[Music]
oh i think you might have a dolly here
oh we got an oh look at that dolly that
is a beauty
that that is a beautiful dollyvarden
it's a member of the char family those
dots
hold them up they have so teeth okay
you pick him up
oh that's the tops of my boots well all
three of the nickels boys have gone over
the tops of their boots so there's no
help in it we're all
wet so we're gonna wait out here a
little bit further and
see if i can't reach that far bank
there's a bit of a shadow forming
that's usually a good place to hit
oh that's a perfect one
look at that here holy [ __ ]
what a beautiful trout oh you got him
buddy you got him keep that rod up keep
the rod up in the air
oh oh that's a big one
i can see him he's gorgeous
oh look at him fight oh he was crazy
hey walk him all the way up hold him
right up
pull him right up
[Music]
high five that was a heck of a fight
nate
another beautiful dying bright silver
is
look at this this is just amazing
what a wonderful place to fish let alone
camp
huh we got a heck of a night ahead of us
jerk it hard jerking hard what you got
there
oh
now he's a beautiful trout
yeah he's a rainbow yeah he's kind of
great
he's awesome nathan what you got
oh nice dolly
nathan's tearing him up he's got two
dollies and a bunch of trout
[Laughter]
he popped off right at the shore and i
had to use some old football techniques
[Music]
well guys i'm gonna be eating barbecued
fresh salmon with corn on the cob but my
boys are a bit more particular so
nathan's got his favorite cup of noodle
and tommy
asked for steak so we got a little bit
of everything for everyone
dancers
so
now
fresh alaskan salmon is one of those
fish it's hard to screw up
hands down my favorite recipe is melted
butter
and brown sugar smothered all over a
filet and grilled
oh so good
there you go a slab of fresh grilled
salmon and corn on the cob man
oh that was so good
i ate that entire fillet by myself
i'll tell you what guys i am absolutely
having a ball
if you're thinking of coming to alaska
and you're on a budget the phantom river
charter drop-off service should be
number one on your list of things to do
it's probably the best deal around
for catching a salmon and if you're not
confident enough to do this on your own
what i would recommend is go with their
charter service their normal guided
trips at the beginning of your trip
figure out what's going on get some
confidence figure out what gear to use
what rigs to use
and then come out here and do this on
your own at the end of your trip
kids settle down to bed
all right guys lay down and go to sleep
the boys are to bed it's gotten dark
and so i started fishing again and
really wasn't getting any action
so i just wandered down the bank a
little bit and i don't know if you can
see this
but there are just tons of fish just
piled up
right up close to shore so i i think
that's the key i just need to go
downstream a little bit
there we go
nice
almost every single silver we're
catching has scars from either gill nets
or seals or orcas or something
these fish everything tries to kill them
well there we go folks
we have officially limited out on silver
salmon
i just might do a little catch and
release fishing
there's another one in like five minutes
there we go
that's another gorgeous dolly garden
i don't know how this day could have
turned out any better
but uh i'm gonna go catch some sleep and
i will see you guys
in the morning
oh
well good morning i think i'm gonna do a
little fishing
so this right here is a pink salmon and
there are
thousands of them right in there okay
all right hit my first peak
there you go i switched to lures to try
to catch some pinks and
there you go i caught one but it's hard
not to snag them i mean there are
literally thousands of them right here
in front of me i don't know if you can
see this but there's easily five 600
salmon in front of me
just piled up in crystal clear water
all right this is why they call them
humpies the males get the big hump on
the back
and there's just thousands of them there
we go another pink
these pinks are just in here thick i'm
getting hit almost every cast
but i should get the fire going and get
breakfast made so the boys have
something warm to wake up to
good morning dad
yeah you got we got a little sun on the
old back
waking up to bacon egg sandwiches um
you know i packed a clean shirt and i
could have swore i packed a clean pair
of pants
but apparently i didn't so i'm wearing
my uh thermals
i think it's a good look for me
all right our boat's here let's get
loaded up we put our bobber out bam bam
bam
got three as soon as we as soon as we
started then
is this cool do you like this tom
oh we had an awesome time if you guys
want to come here and do this
i'll put a link to phantom river
charters website in our video
description
but thanks for watching guys we hope you
enjoyed this video if you want to see
more videos from the outdoor boys
youtube channel
don't forget to click subscribe we put
out new videos
every saturday morning nailed it
if you like this video don't forget to
check out the outdoor boys youtube
channel where we have hundreds of videos
just like this
and don't forget to click subscribe so
you can see other great videos
every saturday morning and hit that bell
button you'll get notifications
thanks for watching